[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días su
magazine 100 dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y estos son nuestros titulares la
organización mundial de la salud
recomendó por primera vez el uso de una
vacuna contra la malaria
el fármaco cuenta con una efectividad de
entre el 30 y el 50 por ciento sin
embargo todavía hay dudas sobre la
producción y distribución del
inmunizante que mata a 400.000 personas
al año en su mayoría niños africanos
áfrica tiene premio nobel de literatura-
se trata del escritor tan sano abdul
razak urna el jurado del nobel destacó
su penetración intransigente y compasiva
en los efectos del colonialismo y el
destino del refugiado en el abismo entre
culturas y continentes
la edición número 28 de la cumbre áfrica
francia tuvo lugar en la ciudad de
montpellier allí el presidente de manuel
macrón fue confrontado por los
participantes en distintos temas como su
política en la región del sahel mientras
el mandatario prometió reconocer las
consecuencias del colonialismo
la organización mundial de la salud
recomendó por primera vez el uso de una
vacuna contra la malaria que alcanza una
efectividad del 30 por ciento
la vacuna será inoculada principalmente
en menores de edad del continente
africano en donde anualmente la malaria
causa la muerte de unas 400.000 personas
sin embargo todavía hay muchas dudas
sobre la efectividad del fármaco además
de su producción y distribución
a partir de hoy la malaria ha terminado
en mi casa
rumbo juliette es una de las tantas
madres de la ciudad decía ya en kenia
que ayudó a sus hijos a recibir la
vacuna contra la malaria solo un día
antes la o ms recomendó por primera vez
un fármaco contra la enfermedad que mata
a 400.000 personas al año la mayoría a
niños africanos
la familia en mi familia ha tenido
grandes problemas a causa de la malaria
necesito mucho dinero para llevar a
naciones al hospital para que reciban
tratamiento con ese dinero podría cubrir
otras necesidades básicas pero ahora que
puedo llevar a mi hijo para que reciba
la vacuna estoy muy agradecida con él
quien es uno de los tres países del
áfrica subsahariana junto a ghana y
malawi que han empezado a desplegar la
vacuna en programas piloto de
inmunización en estos territorios se han
administrado más de 2 millones de dosis
los resultados de la investigación
contribuyeron a su aprobación
el uso de esta vacuna además de las
herramientas existentes para prevenir la
malaria podría salvar a decenas de miles
de vidas jóvenes cada año esta vacuna es
un regalo para el mundo pero su valor se
sentirá más en áfrica value will be felt
most en áfrica
la ms sugiere que los niños en áfrica
sub-sahariana y otras regiones con alta
transmisión de malaria reciban cuatro
dosis hasta la edad de los dos años a
pesar del éxito del plan piloto el
fármaco genera dudas debido a su
efectividad entre el 30 y el 50 por
ciento pero estas no son las únicas
preocupaciones su producción y
distribución también generan preguntas
en medio de la lucha por la pandemia de
las más de 6 mil millones de dosis de
las vacunas contra el coi 19
administradas en el mundo sólo el 2% ha
llegado a este continente
el escritor tan sano abdul razak urna
ganó el premio nobel de literatura su
obra explora los legados del
imperialismo en los individuos
desarraigados de sus raíces con un
enfoque en los jóvenes huérfanos y la
opresión a las mujeres negras en una
sociedad machista juan pabló lo q me
tiene más información
abdul razak urna es el ganador del nobel
de literatura- 2021 nacido en tanzania
en 1948 tuvo que irse a vivir como
refugiado en reino unido a finales de la
década de 1960 su penetración
intransigente y compasiva con los
efectos del colonialismo y el destino
del refugiado en el abismo entre
culturas y continentes lo hicieron el
elegido gobernar gays es desilusión la
mirada de qurna es desilusionada y a
menudo austera y consistentemente
traición a nuestras expectativas de
resoluciones fáciles al mismo tiempo es
un observador compasivo de las
dificultades humanas no es menos
memorable en sus retratos de los jóvenes
huérfanos gente bajo presión oa las
mujeres negras en una sociedad machista
en el rey se ha hecho
el nobel de este año se enmarca en el
cambio que la academia sueca ha aplicado
con miras de bajar el dominio occidental
pues el 81 por ciento de los ganadores
son europeos o norteamericanos
pensé esto es alguien haciéndome una
broma sabes en estos días reciben muchas
llamadas desconocidas y levantas el
teléfono y no sabes quién llama y
alguien te dice has ganado el premio
nobel y piensas o si es el quinto autor
africano en ser galardonado en este
premio y un escritor que no figuraba en
los pronósticos críticos de suecia han
señalado que el asombro de este premio
no era tan grande desde que el chino mo
yan ganó el premio en 2012
la ciudad francesa de montpellier acogió
la edición número 28 de la cumbre áfrica
francia y en la que el presidente manuel
macro fue el único mandatario presente
ya que los líderes africanos no fueron
invitados macrón que quería volver a
conectar con la juventud fue confrontado
en distintos temas como su política en
la región del sahel y los crímenes
cometidos durante la colonización el
evento llega en un momento de fuertes
tensiones entre francia y países como
argelia o mal y antiguas colonias
francesas
emanuel manu quería reconectar con las
nuevas generaciones una juventud
africana que antes de hablar del futuro
reclama un perdón por los crímenes de la
colonización
[Aplausos]
sería una ilusión querer un futuro con
las heridas del pasado
señor presidente el pasado pesa y sigue
pesando
le invito a que asuma compromisos y
decisiones firmes aquí y ahora curro con
él para reconocer y pedir perdón al
continente africano y continua áfrica
el presidente francés se niega una vez
más
bajo el perdón significaría que en
cierto modo
joffré me gustaría desatarme y no creo
en una política de perdón en ningún caso
en el vínculo entre francia y áfrica yo
creo en una política de reconocimiento
los intercambios fueron intransigentes y
probablemente el jefe de estado no
esperaba a ser tan presionado como
cuando una joven maliense le reprochó su
política en el sahel
y dejan estos discursos paternalistas
diciendo que nos van a ayudar que nos
van a ayudar no no necesitamos ayuda
sino cooperación y asociaciones por cien
de acuerdo con lo que acabo de decir
pero no puede decirme debemos tener un
diálogo equilibrado y recíproco y
decirme cuando le hablo de corazón y
digo la verdad que soy paternalista no
soy paternalista soy sincero las
explicaciones continuaron y los miembros
del panel pidieron cambios en las
relaciones entre francia y los países
del continente no más apoyo a regímenes
autoritarios no más ayuda al desarrollo
o sea que la ayuda al desarrollo lleva
más de un siglo en áfrica
no funciona
emanuel manu está de acuerdo en que de
aquí en adelante será una cuestión de
inversión el presidente francés anunció
la creación de un fondo de innovación
para la democracia en áfrica y
finalmente la restitución a finales de
octubre a benin de 26 obras de arte
sacadas de este país
vamos a túnez que volvió a tener
gobierno después de más de dos meses sin
uno el presidente de caixa le tomó
juramento al gabinete de la primera
ministra más la wood en la primera mujer
en ocupar ese cargo no sólo en el país
sino en el mundo árabe 10 de las 25
carteras estarán dirigidas por mujeres
desde ahora tendrán la misión de sacar
al país de una grave situación
financiera y una crisis social y
política que se agudizó desde que el
presidente saleh destituyó al antiguo
gabinete suspendió el parlamento y
concentró todos los poderes lo que ha
provocado multitudinarias protestas en
su contra
tras 11 semanas sin gobierno túnez
vuelve a tener uno liderado por nagla
wood en la primera mujer del mundo árabe
en ocupar este cargo se apoya en varias
personas cercanas al presidente caixa y
es el banquero samir said fue nombrado
ministro de economía y planificación
el abogado taufic charafedín vuelve al
ministerio del interior que ocupó entre
septiembre de 2020 y enero de 2021
durante la investidura puig d´en anunció
los retos futuros
belden uno de los objetivos más
importantes de la historia es combatir
la corrupción que se extiende cada vez
más día a día y conduce a una pérdida de
confianza en cualquier intento de
reforma radical y realidad la flamante
primer ministra recibe un país con una
economía duramente golpeada por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y la corrupción
endémica
pero también deberá tranquilizar a una
comunidad internacional y aun fm y
preocupado para el nuevo equipo los
retos son grandes pero sus prerrogativas
son muy limitadas desde el 25 de julio
el jefe de estado- caixa jet se ha
autoconcedido prácticamente todos los
poderes suspendió el parlamento anunció
su intención de crear una comisión para
modificarla
y ahora está legislando por decreto
durante la ceremonia 7 volvió a
justificar sus acciones
y ya no queremos quedarnos a la sombra
de medidas excepcionales pero
permaneceremos a su sombra mientras
exista un peligro inminente en el
parlamento y en otras instituciones o a
fiat a tener almohadas seattle o foro
para sus opositores y varias ongs esto
no es más que un golpe de estado eso es
lo que denunciaron el domingo al menos
6.000 personas que salieron a las calles
de la capital en contra de la toma de
poder de esta ley
vamos ahora a burkina faso donde fue
aplazado el juicio por el asesinato del
ex presidente thomas sankara que estaba
programado para este 10 de octubre la
medida responde a la solicitud de los
abogados defensores quienes necesitaban
más tiempo para preparar el caso 14
acusados serán juzgados a partir del
próximo 25 de octubre por un tribunal
militar en la capital burkinesa uagadugú
el juicio estuvo cerca de nunca llevarse
a cabo ya que el gobierno de bless
campaoré el ex presidente de burkina
faso y principal inculpado en el caso
bloqueo por 27 años los procedimientos
judiciales no fue hasta su caída en 2014
que se allanó el camino para que el
juicio se pudiera llevar a cabo
hace 34 años que ali traoré espera el
juicio por el asesinato de su compañero
y ex presidente de burkina faso thomas
sankara es el único sobreviviente de la
masacre del 15 de octubre de
1987 un golpe de estado en el que murió
el revolucionario antiimperialista
todo lo que thomas sankara hizo durante
la revolución lleva el sello del amor
hacia su país del amor hacia su pueblo
y en nombre de ese pueblo hizo todos los
sacrificios incluso el de su vida
a pesar de haber sido presidente sólo
cuatro años thomas sankara se convirtió
en una figura legendaria del continente
africano pero la investigación por su
asesinato se desbloqueó únicamente
cuando cayó su sucesor les culpa og en
2014 el ex presidente es el principal
acusado en este juicio pero no asistirá
a la audiencia en uagadugú la capital
los admiradores de thomas sankara piden
respuestas
nuestras expectativas son simplemente
que se cumpla la ley que se diga la
verdad que se arroje luz sobre este caso
sangriento muy sangrientos nuestras
expectativas son que la ley sea igual
para todos que no haya ningún super
ciudadano por encima de los demás
si bien el asesinato de thomas sankara
es objeto de muchas especulaciones sobre
la posible implicación de países
extranjeros esta audiencia se centrará
en los actores burkineses más de 200
periodistas del mundo entero van a
seguir este juicio histórico
para saber quién mató al che guevara de
áfrica
gloria a narváez la monja colombiana que
había permanecido más de cuatro años
secuestrada en malí fue liberada el
pasado 9 de octubre la religiosa había
estado retenida por el frente de
liberación de manzana un grupo yihadista
vinculado a al-qaeda desde el 7 de
febrero de 2017 cuando trabajaba como
misionera colombia atribuyó su
liberación al esfuerzo de varios líderes
africanos y francia- narváez se encontró
frente a frente con el papá francisco en
el vaticano y un día antes se reunió con
el presidente interino de mali así mico
y está expresando su gratitud
hasta aquí este capítulo de áfrica siete
días recuerde que puede repetir esta
misión a través de nuestra página web
www puntos francia 24 punto com
[Música]